momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a
daniela blandón daniela usted no tiene
detalles de las consecuencias económicas
que tuvo el bloqueo de seis días en el
canal de sus cuéntenos cuáles son o la
andrés buenas noches vine l ver qué bien
uno de los por tanto portacontenedores
más grandes del mundo que en cayó hace
seis días en el canal de suez finalmente
fue reflotado la navegación se reanudó
pero eso no quiere decir que la crisis
haya terminado el del bloqueo dejó un
enorme atasco de barcos cerca de 400 y
las autoridades creen que para
despejarlo podría pasar entre 3 y 3 días
y medio los análisis de las consultoras
privadas dicen que las pérdidas por
retención de mercancías diarias han
estado entre 6.000 y 10.000 millones de
dólares este canal que une a asia y
europa mueve cerca del 10 por ciento y
del 10 el 12 por ciento del comercio
mundial por si fuera poco andrés lo
ocurrido en el canal de suez lo que hizo
fue agravar un problema que ya venía de
antes la escasez de contenedores de
envío en asia esto implica que los
minoristas pueden tardar varios días más
y mercancía que va desde televisores
hasta muebles y autopartes entre otros
daniela y el banco mundial mejoró su
previsión de crecimiento para américa
latina y el caribe cuéntenos este
organismo elabora semestralmente un
informe sobre la región y el más
reciente publicado de este lunes dice
que la economía regional podría crecer
4,4 por ciento este año por un efecto de
rebote tras la caída del 6,7 del año
pasado la previsión es mejor que la
anterior que era del 4% y se debe sobre
todo al repunte en el precio de las
materias primas ya que las remesas están
aumentando los países que podrían salir
mejor librados este año serían panamá y
perú con 99 % y 8.1 por ciento
respectivamente le siguen en su orden
argentina chile y colombia por su parte
brasil y méxico- tendrían una
recuperación más modesta desde el banco
mundial también advierte que es muy
posible que siga aumentando la
desigualdad dentro y entre los países
antes
daniela en argentina estaban a punto de
modificar el impuesto a los salarios el
fin de semana fue
de la cámara de diputados un proyecto de
reforma al llamado impuesto a las
ganancias según este proyecto de origen
oficialista los trabajadores que cobren
un salario de hasta 150 mil pesos
argentinos mensuales algo así como 1.600
dólares no son sujetos del impuesto
estos casi 9 veces el salario mínimo
antes para los jubilados el tope va a
ser un poco más alto el gobierno dice
que ese impuesto lo pagan hoy 25 de cada
100 trabajadores y lo que se busca es
que lo paguen 7 de cada 100 es decir lo
pagan 2 millones de personas y se busca
que 1,3 millones no lo sigan haciendo
daniela a los trabajadores de amazon
allanar el camino para crear un
sindicato cuéntenos cómo es eso si
andrés pues casi 6 mil trabajadores de
amazon tuvieron desde comienzos de
febrero y hasta este lunes para votar
sobre si quieren o no crear el primer
sindicato del gigante tecnológico en
suelo estadounidense
el martes iniciaría el conteo de la
votación que podría tomar varios días su
importancia radica en que esto podría
ser un posible impulso para los
empleados de amazon en todo el mundo
recordemos antes que en italia hace unos
días hubo una huelga de unos 30.000
empleados de la empresa de compras en
línea exigen mejores condiciones como
por ejemplo un salario más alto y más
tiempo de descanso asimismo poder ser de
alguna manera partícipes del boom de las
compras en línea durante el la pandemia
con 1,3 millones de trabajadores andrés
amazon es el segundo empleador más
grande del mundo después de uo martín y
su dueño jeff bezos encabeza el ranking
de los multimillonarios daniela momento
de conocer los indicadores o street el
cerró mixto con un nuevo récord en su
principal indicador el dow jones de
industriales en europa hubo pocos
movimientos en el inicio de la semana
santa
fráncfort el cero al alza y londres y
madrid a la baja en américa latina'
tercera alza consecutiva para la bolsa
de sao paulo
y como siempre nuestras cifras del día
en 14 en 40% se desplomó la producción
de carbón de colombia en 2020 estuvo
afectada por el hobbit 19 y una huelga
de tres meses en el cerrejón que es una
de las minas a cielo abierto más grandes
del mundo colombia es el mayor productor
de carbón de la región y el quinto
exportador de carbón térmico del planeta
el año pasado produjo un poco de un poco
menos de 50 millones de toneladas pero
en sus mejores años llegó a producir
casi el doble de eso antes
daniela muchas gracias como siempre por
traernos la información económica aquí
en france24 y ustedes muchas gracias por
sintonizar los invitamos a que continúen
con toda nuestra programación
[Música]
sí